i really am thrilled to be here at
stanford it's just so exciting to be
back with a a large community and you
know working as an artist i work with
teams a lot but i pretty much work you
know on my own not not in a broad
research community so i mean there's a
community of artists but it's not who i
was engaging with on a day to day basis
so it's really fun to be back here
um
i was saying at lunch it's interesting
for me also to think about giving a talk
like this as to what issues would be of
interest to you guys
you know i'm often i really am operating
largely in the fine art community so we
like to talk about you know certain
kinds of conceptual things
but design has always played a really
important role in my work because i am
making installations that engage with
people so i'm going to try to focus a
little bit on the
actual interaction design of the works
that i'm doing
and the first one like when you said
that i'd like to show you is texturing
i created this with a fellow
masters student at the nyu interactive
telecommunications program which is
where i was doing my degree i guess i
should say a little about my background
my undergrad degree was in fine art
but i had i almost double majored in
environmental science so i was always
interested in systems and how the
parameters of a system interacted
and when i saw kind of early cd-roms
this ancient technology which most of
you probably haven't dealt with
interactive cd-roms this is kind of also
in the in the dawn of the internet when
you couldn't really put images and
movies online yet um the ability to
craft a space that like this
metaphorical space that people could
navigate through that was the words we
used at the time
you know by choosing their path of how
they clicked on on different icons or
worked with different imagery
in that that cd-rom space is what got me
interested in programming so i started
learning how to program and eventually
went back to this
program
where i eventually as my thesis project
and then also continuing on as a
researcher at interval research they
sponsored me after i graduated and these
were the kind of projects i was doing so
i'm going to play a little video
tech strain is a playful interactive
installation that blurs the boundary
between the familiar and the magical
participants in the text drain
installation use the familiar instrument
of their bodies to lift and play with
falling letters that do not really exist
like rain or snow the colored text can
be caught
lifted and then let fall again
if a participant accumulates enough
letters along their outstretched arms
they can sometimes catch a word or even
a phrase
oops i thought this was a longer version
of the installation you know what i'm
going to pop over to my dvd
sorry
uh
sorry i'll get to watch that beginning
again there's a lot more so i wanted you
to see the rest of it
tech stream is a playful interactive
installation that blurs the boundary
between the familiar and the magical
participants in the text drain
installation use the familiar instrument
of their bodies to do what seems magical
to lift and play with falling letters
that do not really exist
like rain or snow the colored text
appears to land on participants heads
and arms the text responds to the
participants motions and can be caught
lifted and then let fall again
the falling text will land on anything
darker than a certain threshold and fall
whenever that obstacle is removed
if a participant accumulates enough
letters along their outstretched arms or
along the silhouette of any dark object
they can sometimes catch a word or even
a phrase
the following letters are not random but
form lines of a poem about bodies and
language
so
so we were talking at lunch about um the
text that's actually part of this piece
and you know what is the importance of
that could i switch it to a twitter feed
or something like that
and romy and i really thought carefully
about what that text was it's a poem um
that is about this kind of slippage
between our is it really a conversation
or is something physical happening
between these two people um
and i think we still struggle with this
issue with with all our devices of like
sort of what is where does our body live
in in all of this and so that's that's
sort of a key issue that i i think i've
explored with all of my work
so again this was 1999 so before opencv
like really really early examples
of
computer vision kind of installations um
it was it's interesting to think back on
that time most people were actually the
thing they were most shocked about first
when they saw this was the projector
right so they're like how do you get
that image so big you know and then they
would be like how am i in that image and
then they would come to realize like oh
there's this these texts there's things
i can actually um that can land on my
body um so i like to think too in any
kind of interaction design like what's
that sort of ramp in to discovering more
and more things so once they worked out
that they could catch the letters um at
first that's really exciting but then
there's this whole other layer that whoa
there's actually some words in there
it's not totally random but it's really
hard to read the whole poem so i don't
think that anyone ever gets that all
exactly but part of it is that there is
some meaning that's kind of always just
a little bit outside of your grasp which
again is something that's kind of
interesting to me as an artist um and
then there's the social layer as well so
if you're in the space alone you can
have that kind of interaction but often
like you saw in the video when people
are there
they find different ways to kind of try
to work together or get the letters from
somebody else
and there's a there's a few design
components of this work that i've been
thinking about i just showed it again in
san jose in a show called patent pending
which is all artists who have dealt with
the ip
or ip system in some way or another so
um partly because of the fact i was
employed by interval and their
relationship
with nyu nyu decided to patent this
while i was there so i have engaged i
have a patent well nyu owns that romy
and i are the inventors um
but that that was an interesting show
looking at artists as uh engaging with
with the patent system in different ways
but watching this piece again you know
it's been shown all over the place and i
don't always go to install it anymore so
watching um really young people
encounter this for the first time i'm
always wondering like is there going to
come a point where this kind of
interaction becomes not interesting
anymore right because now we see this
kind of in airports and you know for
advertising it's you know you can do it
with your connect at home you know so
does it does it become a gimmick
um and i think there's a way where it
has even surprised me kind of how people
still find a rich engagement in this
work and i've been trying to analyze
that a bit which is something you all
maybe could help me with since i don't i
don't write research papers on the
actual interaction design but i think
there's some really simple choices that
romy and i made you know maybe
intuitively or justif by luck
that help with that um one of them is
no matter how many people are in this
space they're not occluding or they they
are occluding each other but even if
there's like just this tiny tiny like
fringe at the top where the letters are
falling you can still reach your hands
above other people and get get them and
so just by nature of the fact that
there's something falling from the top
of the screen
even in a really crowded space it's it
the interaction everyone can still have
the interaction
and it actually gets kind of fun that
you're you can stand behind someone and
try to reach above their head to get the
letter so i tried you know i've done
lots of other kinds of installations
using cameras in a silhouette view like
that um and you always have this problem
that if someone's behind the other
person they're kind of not part of the
interaction in some way so that that
maybe was just luck based on on this
idea that we were exploring um the fact
that the people are in black and white
and the letters are in color i think is
important so i think there's this this
idea and a lot of interactive
installation that the more we add the
better it is
you know the sort of more
hyper-realistic it is the more you feel
like you're in the actual environment um
but i think there's a kind of there's
something very compelling about seeing
yourself in black and white which kind
of removes you from reality and the
letters being in color so there's always
this distinction between the thing
you're engaging with and your
representation of yourself
um we often argue with people
back to my powerpoint
not argue but um when we install this
piece let's go back to this one
um
about you know it's it's pretty hard to
get the camera always in the middle of
the screen it means you can't use a
screen like this you have to cut a hole
in the wall
and everyone always would prefer can't
you put the camera on top of the screen
or below the screen
but there's a really simple reason why
that's super critical which is people's
line of sight
right so if you've ever skyped and had a
camera that wasn't the camera in your
laptop when we used to have the other
ones it could be somewhere else you
realize how totally distracting it gets
when you're you can't look at the other
person in the screen and make kind of
eye contact with them which is just an
illusion of where the camera is right so
now since the camera's right here when
i'm skating with someone it's pretty
close to my line of sight similarly to
how here we have it in the middle of the
screen if it was up above it'd kind of
be looking down at you and you wouldn't
like literally be able to look at
someone else the way these people are in
the screen so there's this this real
illusion that you can communicate with a
person standing right next to you by by
looking in this sort of mirror like
space together
um
let's see what else do i want to say
i think that's it for now
i'm sure i'll leave time for questions
about this um but again this idea of
what's what's the role of our body in
relation to these systems and i guess
one other thing my favorite moment in
that video is when the little boy turns
the umbrella upside down
right because he's making a hypothesis
about how the system works and is is
then making his next attempt to test it
out right if i can catch the letters on
the top of the umbrella what happens if
i turn the umbrella upside down so i
think those kind of moments are what
really got me hooked on on being an
interactive artist so this was really
one of the first major pieces i did
and then i just wanted to keep doing it
because because of creating those kind
of spaces for people
um
i started thinking more about
the way we use language in relation to
our body so we often say like what's
your position on this issue
where do you stand
right and we mean that like you know
what are your political views or what's
your you know scholarly position on this
um but i was thinking about
about that as in a very literal sense
like that that stems from a literal
position that you may be standing in and
i wanted to create a place a space that
again was a multi-user
uh so thinking back again to this time
it this this idea of a social engagement
with a computer was very very different
than it is now so i wanted to create
that kind of space
um
but i was thinking about could i could i
make a shared space on the screen
that also represented like literally
having these different viewpoints so
that it wasn't a coherent space
um in a sort of linear one-point
perspective photographic way right so
computers are really really good at
rendering something you know based on
this formula that we have a camera over
here and these objects here and we're
going to project them onto a flat plane
which is the computer you know then
we'll render that and that'll be the
computer's computer screen but if you
look at art history that's that that
kind of way of depicting space is a very
small part of our history
and there's lots of artists that have
worked with other ways of of creating
space um and representing reality a
reality so like picasso and the cubists
um you know like to position lots of
different things together on the screen
on their painting surfaces so i was
thinking about that um
i'll let you watch this and then i'll
explain a little more how i got there
and so the original this is a series i
continued so what i'm showing you is
actually a more recent piece in this
series
shifting time san jose is an interactive
video installation that juxtaposes the
past and present using the viewer's body
as the interface to navigate between
different times
in this piece
commissioned by the city of san jose for
a new terminal of the san jose
international airport
viewers first encounter a projected
still image
as they walk closer to the projection
wall the surface disrupts
revealing deeper moments of time in the
pre-recorded video clips
viewers are able to shift between past
and present by moving towards and away
from the projection wall
shifting time san jose continues
utterback's liquid time series which
uses her custom software to deconstruct
the video frame as the unit of playback
this strategy of fragmentation allows
multiple moments to appear
simultaneously and speaks to the
possibilities of digital tools as well
as the fluidity of our personal memories
unlike the previous liquid timepieces
shifting time san jose
extends the period of time depicted from
seconds to decades
in this work high definition video
footage from the present blends with
archival film footage from the 1920s
through the 1960s
each of the 20 scenes in shifting time
san jose pairs footage of a historic
site or activity in the san jose area
with complementary contemporary footage
some scenes depict recognizable
locations in both the past and present
other scenes show people working at
industries long gone paired with
employees in the current high-tech
sector
pleasure and travel scenes from past
eras are paired with their contemporary
counterparts
different forms of stasis and change are
revealed as time shifts subtly within
each clip and more drastically between
the different eras of historic time
as the past visually intersperses with
the present
shifting time san jose creates an
intriguing visual metaphor of how both
history and our memories of a place
contribute to our experience of the
present moment
so in the end the piece the piece i
developed is still using um you know one
point linear perspective as as conveyed
by a lens um but that wasn't sort of
where i started that's that's where the
piece ended up so one thing that's great
about being an artist is you can kind of
follow the mistakes and and take
advantage of the things that are
happening so what i first started doing
when i was set out to do this is i
imagine the space in front of the screen
is kind of having maybe seven or eight
different zones in it and as you move
forward and backward closer or further
away from the screen you would get
whatever type of imagery was in those
those zones
and i was coding this myself so it had
these lists of the different images that
you were kind of moving through as you
move back and forth and different people
could be in like a different layer at a
time because if i was you know this
person could be there and i could be
here so i liked that idea that you were
getting these different perspectives
together
and i sort of kept making more and more
and more layers and this list was
getting longer and longer and i had this
very like aha moment that a list of
images in the computer is a video file
which is sort of obvious but i think a
lot of people don't understand that if
you haven't been sort of trying to
access one image and print it to the
screen and get the next image in the
queue um so i decided hey what would
happen if if these layers that you were
moving through were kind of infinitely
thin and it was actually each one was a
frame
of you know 24 frames per second or
whatever video so that visually was a
lot more interesting than my original
premise
um and in the earlier pieces like the
voiceover said it was it would be one
clip that you were moving through so
like 10 seconds of time not like what
you just saw where i was pairing up that
the present five seconds or ten seconds
with a really deep past another five or
ten seconds um if you want to think i
think a lot of people have now seen this
it's often called slit scan i didn't
know about that when i was first working
on this but there as soon as you start
looking at the um
the frame data as digital information
it's very easy to take a slice of that
video frame right like when video was
was um film and it was like
literally um
you know a celluloid square after a
celluloid square after a cellulite
square it's really hard to physically
take a little stripe of that out and put
it next to another one but once it's
it's in the computer you can easily get
at any pixel so i think there's a lot of
people now kind of experimenting in this
way where they're pulling um they're
looking at that volume of video data as
data not frame by frame by frame but
it's a sort of interesting premise like
just because we recorded this
information in one structure why do we
have to play it back using that same
structure
and for those of you that aren't really
familiar with this a way to think about
it is that if you imagine the video is a
flip book that's stapled along the top
you know like one of those little paper
flip books and then cut a whole bunch of
slices in it vertically then you can
flip any of those vertical strips
independently of each other so that's
sort of the effect that i'm creating um
and i think another important thing
which wasn't obvious to me at the time
but like the more and more popular
different computer vision systems become
is that in both text reading this i'm
kind of using a really dumb
algorithm because i was just learning
how to do all this i don't have any kind
of skeleton constructed
in either of these pieces i don't even
have blob detection like i don't even
know that this area is a person i'm
really just looking at the contours of
your body
right so in text screen the space is set
up very specifically so there's a white
wall behind you so even if you're
wearing a white shirt
you're darker than the wall you know so
there's no reference frame for those of
you that do computer vision so it's just
looking for dark
above a certain threshold which i set up
in this space um and in this piece it's
really doing the same thing but the
camera's on the ceiling looking down so
like your nose is deeper into time than
your shoulders um but what i found is
there's more and more of these tools are
available it's actually like we're
dumbing down the body
right so even though we have a very
sophisticated model like what you can
get through the um the connect
api
you know we know exactly where the
joints are and how your hands are moving
a lot of really rich information is
thrown out i think or it's not it's not
actively used as much as it could be so
if you think about the in texturing like
how
someone's arms like the letters can
really um build along their contour or
in this piece how you know like what i
just said your nose is actually deeper
than your shoulders and you get these
kind of really interesting um
undulations i feel like a lot of that
has is sort of not being used in a lot
of the not all but in a lot of the
computer visions vision systems that i
see it's like because we have this other
higher level information we've kind of
lost some of what the camera can give us
as an input device so that's something
i've been thinking about a little bit
lately
um
i want to point out this uh circle of
light on the floor too
um when i first did this piece i didn't
indicate the interaction area at all and
it was kind of a failure
because people couldn't understand like
that they could see all this energy
changing but it wasn't super obvious to
them especially like at an opening when
there was a lot of people around
where the interaction was in the space
because there's no indication of your
body unlike text rate it's really clear
when you're in or out of the piece
and so i started experimenting with
different ways to indicate that some of
the failed ones were like at one gallery
i had there was a very shiny floor and i
put some like sort of thin pvc stuff
down like kind of matte you know like
doormat kind of stuff and people started
doing this
right because you're giving them this
indication that that's some sort of
sensor on the floor
um and so their testing out of the
system was giving them the completely
the wrong clue um so i tried other ways
of marking the floor and in the end this
this sort of square of light um is
something i've used and some of the
other pieces i'll show you too because
there's a really nice connection between
the projection being light and this
light on the floor
being the same you know indicated not
with pain or not with something else
that wouldn't confuse people that it was
a sensor
but it has sort of the same visual
characteristics so i just wanted to
point that out um and in the airport
piece the video we couldn't get this
kind of rectangle because of the height
of the ceiling so we did little corner
squares which would not be
not my preference but
this is the piece of the airport again
so just some images this is one of my
favorites it was really fun to shoot the
archival footage or we looked for the
art sorry we did all the research to
find the archival footage and then we
had to figure out what to pair it with
but this one of the women's sorting
fruit and the woman programming this
idea of again what's the role of our
body in these different forms of work
is interesting to me
so the next series i'm going to show you
i won't show you all the pieces but it's
kind of an extended
uh series i've done called external
measures
where i started thinking about could i
make
something on a screen that was a drawing
system
that you know is algorithmically
reacting to people's movement in the
space
that that both generated something
visually interesting and was also
interesting for people physically as
they interacted in the space right so i
think if you guys think about other
kinds of interactive art that you've
seen there are a lot of projects where
the interaction is sort of conceptual
meaning
it might be important to the idea of the
piece but you it's very hard for you to
experience it right
you it's very hard for you to test how
it's actually reacting to you or you
have these mistaken cues like i was
talking about
um
so i was it was really important to me
in these that you could
like the little boy turning over the
umbrella like slowly test the different
parts of the system and how it was
reacting to you um so this was the first
one um you can see how people are
indicated as they're the negative space
so their bodies actually erase what's on
the screen
and i'm not going to show video of this
one because it was one of the earlier
ones
but the um there was like a network of
little gray lines that was always
spinning and whenever it intersected
with you it had to this i got blob
detection working so
you would be assigned a color when you
walked into the space and anything that
hit you would turn that color and then
keep going so there was also this sense
that you had influenced this bigger
system
but it was doing its own thing
independently of you
there's a screenshot of it
and then these are two of the next
pieces untitled five and untitled six
and i'm going to show you video of
untitled five and you know what i'm
going to flip back to the dvd because
this might be a short one too i didn't
test these videos bad
untitled five is the fifth interactive
installation in the external measures
series which utterback has been
developing since 2001.
the goal of these works is to create an
aesthetic system which responds fluidly
and intriguingly to physical movement in
the exhibit space
in these dynamic works the position's
velocity and existence of various parts
of a projected image depend on people's
presence and movement
some responses are direct and immediate
other behaviors evolve over time based
on the flow of people in the space
in untitled five a network of gray lines
flickers around one's body and
immediately indicates your presence
a colored line is drawn along your
trajectory
when you leave the installation this
line is filled with tiny marks
these marks can now be pushed from their
location by other people's movement
displaced marks attempt to return to
their original location
creating smears and streaks of color as
they move
these painterly swaths are the results
of intersections between current and
previous motion in the space
conceptually linking disparate moments
in time
untitled 5 reacts to stillness as well
as motion
standing in place sets off a delicate
spray of dots which radiate from the
center of one's body
while one's presence generates marks it
also erases older marks
the rules of untitled five are carefully
constructed to create an overall
composition that is organic open and
evocative while still being completely
algorithmic
while the specific rules of the system
are never explicitly revealed to
participants the internal structure and
composition of the piece can be
discovered through a process of
kinesthetic exploration
engaging with this work creates a
visceral sense of unfolding or
revelation
but also a feeling of immediacy and loss
that was the floor that didn't work very
well that
the experience of this work is the
experience of embodied existence itself
a continual flow of unique and fleeting
moments
so in this i was kind of splitting the
difference of those of two ways of
looking at at human movement that i was
just talking about so the line that's
being drawn obviously i'm reducing you
to a point it's the center of your blob
but that kind of gray mesh around the
outside of your body still has that
richness of really the contours of what
you look like
and the other thing
that i think
is still kind of unique about this piece
compared to some similar types of
installations is that it's not just
doing one thing there's not one rule
right so in text reading the rule is
really simple the letters have to land
on anything that's darker than the
background but there is a richness both
because of the way it's it's it's
following the contours of your body and
the fact that there's text that you can
or cannot decipher and the social
interactions that develop but the actual
rule of the system is very very simple
um very same same with the liquid time
piece right though i described how
you're like flipping through these
pieces of video but it's kind of one
rule there's not a lot
there's a little bit of how far you get
those strips messed up they take a
little time to return to stillness but
it's really the same rule set in these i
was really looking at them as a kind of
larger composition like how could i as
an artist think of each of these rules
as sort of one element and a bigger
picture no no pun intended
and how did each of those rules function
in in the overall experience so some of
them like the line the little gray lines
really help you find where you are
the other one tells you something about
time passing right because the line is
building up
and then i think what's most interesting
about this piece and this is the one in
the series where i really got to this
was that the things that are happening
don't just have to do with you
right so a lot of our interaction design
it's very sort of like egocentric and
it's all about you and everything you're
doing and you you you right and
immediately immediately immediate
immediate feedback
right so but with this system um what
the voiceover is trying to describe is
that
i'm looking at the visual marks that get
laid down as a sort of history
but because it's it's not a paint line
that's fixed it's actually a history
that's in code
i can then have the people in the space
that come later
that have their movement intersect with
that past movement
so i don't know if that made sense from
the voiceover but like if i if i walk in
one line through the space the little
marks are holding their sizes based on
how fast i was going
and they obviously know the xy position
that they got laid down on if another
person walks through they have to get
pushed away
so there's already one interaction
between the past and the present but
they have a rule that they're trying to
go back then when the second person gets
out of the way to their original
location so the the thing that's drawing
the most in this piece is that
difference between someone that was
there in the past where they walked and
someone that was there now so i think
again this is an area that there's still
a lot of
space to explore that
of how we can show these connections
between different uh different moments
in time
and i don't think people ever under
figure this all out either so in terms
of the interaction design hopefully what
makes these works compelling you know
there's a lot of collectors that now
have them um either in lobbies or homes
um they're not like a one-liner right
but they're also not
inscrutable
so when you walk into this installation
you can find yourself like you can test
oh there's my arm you know i see myself
um you can see some things that are very
clearly reacting to you and understand
why but there's there's that
layer of connection with the past that's
always a little hard to totally decipher
so it doesn't become predictable
and i think those again are kind of
metaphors of interaction
we could stand to think more about
there it is in a lobby
and here unfortunately i wasn't able to
convince them to do any kind of light on
the floor the ceiling was pretty low so
and and often here's the problem being
an artist too i install these things and
i don't always get a chance to go back
and analyze what's happening so this is
a lobby in hong kong i can't really tell
you if how much people there um
understand the piece but the the fact
that it's a it's a residential lobby and
people live there makes me think that
eventually they would
come to sort of understand what uh where
the interaction area is here
and here's i had a chance to install all
three of these at the milwaukee art
museum and this was the first time i i
really started making some conclusions
about how
the animations that were generated in
each work change people's behaviors
so in like the first piece that was
always moving which you didn't see video
of i noticed this is very anecdotal so
i'd love an hdi person to analyze this
more fully at some point i found it made
people really twitchy because every time
they walked into the space they affected
the system they left it started
rewriting over where they were it's like
you don't like this idea that whatever
you just inscribed into this piece is
vanishing so people would like fee they
were much more like in out in out in out
whereas untitled five which i just
showed you you know once it comes to
stillness it stays that way even if it's
three hours until another person comes
into the space so people would step out
and watch the work and then it was
almost like the opposite if you stepped
into the interaction area you were
making a state change from it being
still and really beautiful to who knows
if you're going to mess it up or you
know you're activating it again so there
was almost i wouldn't say a hesitation
because people would get really excited
but it felt very different to step into
that piece than in
into the piece on the left even though
you know sort of ostensibly they're just
all these drawing systems um so i think
there's a lot there could be some
interesting research in there i'm going
to go a little faster through some of
these bigger pieces which is mainly what
i've been doing for the past i guess six
or seven years
this is 2007 on the san jose city hall
so i had a chance to put a camera up in
the dome and watch the whole plaza
um a lot of things didn't work well
scaled up so luckily it was a temporary
installation but i got to change it
every night so the pictures of it look
really different i was trying to figure
out
also because this surface is so
complicated like how to help people see
themselves in some of those ways i was
talking about before so i had to get
sort of more and more obvious and more
and more bold for people to see
um and i started trying to do things
like um have certain behaviors when a
group would form which were sort of
moderately successful there's me like
testing one program and running another
one and then i would swap things over
the next day if i liked what i had been
so there's two parallel
machines that are each with the same
camera input
originally i wanted to skim this surface
to make a nice clean surface
you learn a lot of interesting things
working with public spaces that was not
allowed on the city hall because it
would have set a precedent for hanging
banners on the city hall
so i had to work with the surface that
was there which in the end turned out to
be really kind of beautiful
um
you know how the light was hitting all
these the front layer and this back
layer so that idea comes back in the
last piece i'll show you
um this is a piece called aurora oregon
sorry that piece is called abundance um
this is aurora organ from 2009 um it's
in a movie theater like the lobby of a
movie theater in st louis park minnesota
it's right outside of minneapolis
um
i'm going to talk a tiny bit about
the um the space as as part of the um
interaction design um so the piece i'll
show you a video clip of it in a second
but there's there's capacitance sensors
along the hand railing and how people
touch that affects the patterns and the
hanging lights
but the original spec that i was asked
to summon a proposal for was to create a
video piece an interactive video piece
like what you've been seeing on this
wall here
um there's a lot of problems with that
number one it's this huge glass atrium
right i was like this is you know the
budget is not
big enough to have the projector power
to cover that um but i also didn't think
that that from the way that people would
walk through this space made a lot of
sense right they talked about um the the
stakeholders here talked about wanting
to create a social interaction and a
sense of drama and a space and i thought
well you know the people are coming into
this space through these stairs coming
up these escalators and if you want to
create a social interaction don't you
want to focus people around that like
not have them be standing looking at
this other wall
um
so my proposal was to activate the
handrailing as the site of the
interaction again to focus people in not
have them all be looking up
at this other wall
and i said if you have a physical if the
output of this interaction is physical
even if there are times of the day where
the leds are also going to be struggling
against the sun
it has a presence it's not just gone
so it activates the space visually even
when it's not totally visible so here's
a little clip of it
i think
let's go back to the dvd
dvd to the rescue
aurora organ is a contemporary
meditation on the possibilities of
translating human presence into light
using digital technology
commissioned by forecast public art and
duke realty for the city of st louis
park minnesota
this site-specific interactive sculpture
is installed in the 80-foot atrium of
the showplace theaters located at the
shops at west end in st louis park
the piece combines custom software rgb
leds touch sensors and traditional
sculptural materials to create an
intriguing experience for theater goers
as people touch or tap the handrailing
around the building's stairwell these
intimate gestures are amplified into
architectural scale patterns of light
in the aurora organ sculpture six light
columns hang at various elevations above
the theater entrance
on the second floor landing six
illuminated glass sensors are inset in
the wooden handrailing and cycle through
a palette of colors beckoning viewers to
approach
each time a person taps or touches a
railing sensor a pulse of the current
railing color is added to the
corresponding column
the length of each pulse depends on the
length of time a person touches the
railing
holding the railing sensor creates a
long streak of color while tapping
creates shorter bursts
new colors overlay and blend with
previous patterns in the columns
creating a record of past and present
activity at the railings
each column of aurora organ becomes a
temporal history and amplified visual
trace of people's presence and activity
in the atrium
the colors of light in each column move
about in various ways going faster or
slower traveling up or down depending on
how people tap or touch the railing
if two or more participants hold down
their sensors completely filling their
columns with color the colors start
jumping from column to column
if people around the stairwell cooperate
touching all six sensors simultaneously
general properties of the system like
gravity are reversed causing a major
change in the behavior of all the
colored elements
further hidden behaviors are revealed
the more people engage with the
sculpture
while the patterns created by people's
actions in aurora organ are ultimately
transient the bursts of light created by
the most recent participants continue to
cycle in the columns even after these
people have gone
left alone aurora organ echoes these
patterns in the empty lobby
dreaming of the touches of people who
are no longer there
so
you know the more and more um
sort of
actual public space we lose right like
this is a private uh
private movie theater
um i've been trying to consider ways
where within that structure people can
feel connected to those spaces it
doesn't solve the political issues of
those public spaces turning more and
more private
but the idea similarly to the city hall
where you
can sort of
put something of not just your tweet
feed or twitter feed or not just your
thoughts but with something of your
physicality you know you can't you can't
add uh color to this piece unless you
actually touch the hand railing right
it's literally a record of that that
physical interaction
so i want to show you we go till two
is that right
yeah
i'll give you five minutes and then
we'll have
15 minutes two or five okay cool um i
want to talk a little about the sensor
design the capacitance sensors in these
hand railing
there's the piece again
which i worked with
a great engineer
and the team of people on this whole
project so these all these projects and
starting to scale up in terms of the
team
but figuring out how to do something
that felt nice
i wanted to do sandblasting but that
collects a lot of oil from your hands
the sandblasting we needed to diffuse
the light so you didn't see the leds in
there so we worked really hard on these
combinations of materials also finding
the capacitance sensor to be clear so
the light could get through it um
how to hook them all together
how to get the wiring through this hand
railing and still have it pass code so
it has to still allow an impact of a 250
pound person running at a certain speed
um and with a safety factor of five
which was pissed off my engineer who was
used to medical devices which safety
factor of five for that kind of thing
was not what he was used to
but we figured it all out um a thing i'm
particularly proud of is that they're um
there are these units you can take out
so if we ever have a maintenance problem
we actually
made and stained at the same time as the
handrailing pieces of wood you can put
back in and screw back in and these just
plug out so they can send them back to
us to get fixed which actually likely
hasn't happened yet
but in public art thinking about that
this is ian smith high spirits who did
the programming of the dmx programming
for the
leds um and this is my favorite part so
we weren't allowed to modify these uh
the vertical pieces of the handrailing
so the question was how to get the
cabling
down into the floor which all that guts
is had to exist somewhere in the floor
um and so if you look at this
it's a secret uh collar that hides that
which i thought was really great because
you really don't notice it at all but it
allowed us we were allowed to drill a
hole
into the larger pipe part but we weren't
allowed to modify the actual connection
point because that had already been
rated the the engineering that had
already been done and we weren't allowed
to change it that's brett the engineer i
worked with and alan who also helped us
we did a lot of prototyping of the
columns to um to figure out what would
be the best this was a brilliant move on
my part i must say one you know there's
those things you're like that was the
smartest thing i did on this whole
project which was to hang pool noodles
first um because the the columns are
actually kind of delicate and you know
you're up on a 70-foot lift hooking them
on
we've done lots of cad models in a
physical model of what we thought the
heights would be
but i wasn't sure right the physical
world is really different than a cad
model
and so we actually did make a lot of
changes on site with the pool noodles
before we hung the actual thing so we
got the heights all locked in but people
were really funny they thought that was
the artwork for a while what is this we
don't understand this contemporary art
um
i think that's all i want to say about
that i want to skip ahead
and show you
i will show you two other projects
um
very quickly this was a piece i did for
it was the 75th anniversary of the
golden gate bridge so it was a temporary
show in fort point which is the civil
war era fort that's under
under the bridge um i had this space
here which is one of the old batteries
that is literally like where the
bridge comes over the space
so kind of following on this idea i was
talking about the hand railing like how
do you focus people's attention through
your design on where they actually are
and how they engage with other people in
this space
i wanted people to think about the fact
that they're right under the bridge
going going across here and also think
about the history of the the piece of
land that they were standing on which i
thought you know i had this great idea
that the the shores of the of the san
francisco bay changed so much over time
that i wanted to visualize that somehow
the reason the bridge is built where it
is is because those are the most
unchanging the most solid rock part of
the bay which is like obvious once i
thought about it so um it turned out
that there wasn't a lot of change in
those areas of the shore but so the idea
is to have monitors in this space and
that are like pieces of a map of that
shoreline that have the bridge um in the
map matches the bridge that's going
right over your head there
so there you see the monitors
with that
and there's the foot of the bridge so
the bridge you're looking at in the maps
is like really right out the window
and those are the the pieces of the maps
i pulled and so what i did was um
i was inspired by these uh fisk maps of
the mississippi which show how how the
mississippi has changed geologically its
path over time and i wanted to show that
kind of deep uh geological time
in the maps that i was in some interface
i was building for these maps
so what i ended up doing play this
was finding 20 different maps um in the
berkeley map archive and again i thought
i was going to see the shoreline change
the shoreline doesn't really change at
all what changes is how we depict it
so this piece really
became for me about showing our changing
technologies of printing or changing
technologies of cartography and sort of
blurring them together having them
burble up in between each other right so
you don't just see each map one by one
by one so this kind this piece has a lot
of relationship to the liquid time piece
i showed you where um it's pulling
algorithmically in the sort of wavering
shape of the shoreline from all these
different maps
um so stewart card and i were having
this conversation at lunch about you
know
this is a kind of i don't know if this
is even an information visualization
oh and the water comes in every once in
a while and washes it all away thinking
again about our span of time versus this
geological spirit of time but i do think
it gives us a different way to think
about this kind of imagery and what's
our relationship to that shoreline
and i'm just going to show you let's see
i have one minute i'm going to go three
minutes more because i want to show you
what i'm currently working on which are
glass projects so partly from abundance
which was that projection onto the city
hall partly because projection when it's
sunny out you don't really see it
working on longer term commissions
people are very wary of spending a lot
of money on technology that they don't
know i can't guarantee these pieces are
going to run in 30 years right i think
that's probably unrealistic
so i've been trying to think about how
do i make these hybrids that could have
a physical component and a digital
component so i started um working with a
glass company in munich to
develop this piece
um which i will show a quick video these
were testing acetate patterns that i
then will project onto which you'll see
in the video
and as i was experimenting i worked out
that having two layers of glass
really gives you a sense of depth so we
literally projection mapped the imagery
onto the first layer the back layer and
the back wall
which where's the video
it's working
with the fabricators we had it we tested
you know all the colors
everything
and here's the piece
so i just finished this this fall
and this is last thing i'll show you
flourish is a 70 foot long site specific
installation commissioned for a major
thoroughfare in a corporate headquarters
in boston massachusetts
the work combines utterback's
interactive installation techniques with
a new display method
projection onto multiple layers of
custom
glass utterback created the interactive
content for flourish with animator and
frequent collaborator michelle higa fox
flourish consists of seven distinct
panels
a triptych seen from a connecting glass
walkway
and a set of four panels along the
extended thoroughfare
three of the panels in the hallway are
interactive
the glass panels and flourish contain
hand-painted areas of iridescent opaque
and translucent glazing along with
intricate sandblasted details each panel
functions as a static work of art
but at certain times of day a new
dimension is revealed through the
interactive projections
the double layers of glass in each panel
give the projected light actual physical
depth
projected elements can land on opaque
glass in the front panel
back panel or travel all the way through
to the background wall
the varied surface of each panel allows
projected light to reflect off the
opaque areas
combined with the glazing colors
and cast focused shadows behind the
intricate sandblasting
the complex effects of the projected
light hitting different surfaces and
depths in the glass creates a mysterious
viewing experience
where viewers must decipher what is
static and what is changing
as viewers walk by the interactive
panels their movements are tracked by
overhead video cameras
projected elements that correspond to
the glass designs react to viewers
presence
dynamic swaths of color and swirls of
particles trace viewers movements along
the hall
so i'm just gonna
mute the audio and talk over it now so
what's really interesting is being in
this space and people have no idea what
they're looking at like people walk
through and be like what is like where
what what how you know because the depth
even of these two inch differences
between the wall and the different
layers of glass is not something we're
used to seeing we have screens
everywhere but they're totally
two-dimensional any depth rendered on
those screens unless you're using 3d
glasses is is an illusion
that we've worked out
with linear perspective or other kinds
of occlusion and visual tricks on those
screens so this is a new direction i'm
going in i've also been experimenting a
bunch with transparent lcd screens and
creating interaction through the screen
so you know our screens generally when
we're looking at our screen we might be
texting or you know chatting with
someone who's not there so it's social
but again your body is kind of gone from
that interaction they take us off and
away from the people that are standing
right around us so i think there's
there's a lot of potential with the
transparent lcds to create
interactions where you're looking at
each other through these surfaces or
again these that are just really using
what the richness of your body in our
actual depth perception
so that's some of the work i'm going to
be working on here
i'm also working
with mark fringer dance company which is
a ballet company
on doing some
camera tracking for a performance he's
doing this fall on wc so if anyone is
interested in that i'm definitely
looking looking for people to work with
me on that
and wendy reminded me i should mention
i'm teaching
i'm mainly a lot of the courses i'm
doing this quarter and ongoing are with
the the graduate design students but
some of the ones that are open to
everyone the one i'm doing this spring
is called time shift so we're looking at
ideas of time and how artists
sometimes are maybe ahead of culture in
terms of visualizing new ways of
thinking about time or sometimes helping
us understand you know how our
technologies change how we think about
time so it's pretty funny it's a studio
class though so you're actually making
things um around these themes
so
we have
10 minutes for questions no 15 minutes
per question
kind of evaluate your own work uh but by
then what i mean is you know um some
people might interact with your piece by
you just you know being entertained and
playing around with it for a few minutes
and then move on or some people you may
you know spend a longer time trying to
really understand what what's what's
happening and maybe
get you know all the way to the theme
that you have in mind when you're
designing the piece and so i'm just kind
of curious what
do you have some sort of reaction of the
people in mind when you design a piece
or are you
um you know how do you know okay like
this worked out this didn't work out you
know like i'm just curious how you
evaluate that i guess you know
art is it's very how you value it is
obviously very different than like a
functional interface where there's a
specific task that that is a goal um i
think i alluded to it a little when i
was talking about just something kind of
endure right like i would what i'm
hoping to do is make pieces of art you
know like the paintings that we treasure
in museums that that people want to keep
looking at you know years and years and
different times in your life or like you
can sit in front of it for a long time
like that there's something about it
that is is rich enough that you don't
just look at it and want to get sick of
it and throw it out you know never see
it again um so it's it's that kind of
idea of like is it
disposable or does is there a
is there something enough that when you
go back or walk through this hallway i
mean this the last piece i just showed
you is in um it's a corporate hallway so
people go by there every day so do they
stop looking at it or is there something
about it that's going to continue to
hold their attention
i don't think again because it's an
artwork that you know sometimes people
walk through the hallway and they're
busy and they're talking to someone so
they're not they're gonna have a very
more peripheral interaction with it and
other times they might spend more time
with it so it's more about that span of
deeper time than
that you know any specific interaction
um in fact that was something i talked
about um
in you know the late 90s early 2000s
with the
pieces like texturing and liquid time
that
the metaphor of interaction at that time
was really more like a book or a movie
like you would sit down at the computer
and interact with it and i talked about
those pieces as being ambiently
interactive
meaning you can still be having
confidence you can be doing something
else while you're interacting with them
which is sort of now because of our
devices are so small and we're always
doing that it's almost like the opposite
problem now it's like how do we how do
we have attention to anything um because
we're so distracted
but i think there's a way where it's
okay that you can scale you know we do
that with music you kind of have it in
the background or you really listen to
it sometimes so i think
allowing people to determine how they
want to interact with it
is is okay as long as it doesn't get
boring
that was a long answer
um you use technologies like you
mentioned video the touchscreens like
their way to the projection kind of
mapping
um to keep people like right on the edge
of what they're used to seeing so that
they kind of look at it a different way
so like i guess right now what would be
like the technologies that you'd think
that you know would be interesting to
work with to like now keep people on the
edge of what they're used to seeing
um yeah i just did a proposal for these
trans transparent lcds um which is
something i'm really interested also
flexible screens again because i think
that kind of shatters this idea of of
screens being windows these rectangular
things that we're always looking through
it's you know like there's so much more
we could be thinking about in that but
we've sort of been limited by what's
commercially available
so i'm hoping you know maybe with the
research i'm doing here to make some
prototypes that would help open new
possibilities for that um i didn't show
a bunch of pieces i did with other kinds
of sensors they're on my website the
potent objects or like accelerometers um
in snow globes with video screens in
them that you know now again like
iphones have accelerometers so that
seems kind of normal but that was when i
did those it was sort of before that so
i don't even know if it's that i i want
to use these kind of early like bleeding
edge technologies
because they're things people haven't
seen it's just that i'm curious about
that like i really like
combine it yeah
i'm not used to seeing myself in that
kind of setting and they weren't at that
point right
but so then the question is going back
to the question right before yours is it
still interesting now and i was saying
that that show i was just sad the answer
was really yes i think because of some
of the actual things in in the piece
that are happening somebody didn't even
like the the letters are also always
fading too so it does have this sense
that like you can't ever quite you know
it's not a it's not a kind of perfect
interaction but that's a little bit more
interesting so um but yeah i'm really
interested in the sculpture of
possibilities of screens and things that
use our depth perception which i just
it's part of this whole idea that
how does this stuff like limit our body
and what we're really good at or how
does it really respond to it and so i'm
hoping that that's a new kind of area of
hope that that we can
not i mean answering my eyes hurt
sometimes when i look at the screen so
much so it's like that's because you're
looking at this light bulb flat light
bulb you know so like e-ink surfaces and
things like that is something i think
i'll be working with a bunch
and just to critique myself i feel like
the interaction and the piece i just
showed you is a little dumbed down maybe
that's strong but i mean part of it is
that people that's not a place people
are going to stand and hang out in that
hallway so
there is a sense that reacting to this
quick movement back and forth is
appropriate maybe for that space but it
was also just a matter of time
allocation on that project i really
wanted to work on on that depth and
getting that richness in there and the
the interaction design
maybe suffered a bit from that
i'll take online
things like to learn during your
prototyping process influence the
interaction of design do you just like
start with like the vision and
prototyping is just to see whether it's
buildable or if you actually go through
the whole like in the design and
prototyping validation process um i try
to do as much as i can you know
sometimes again just because of the time
frame i don't get to do as much in the
aurora organ piece which is the led
piece
i made a big mistake because of how i
was prototyping in my studio which you
may remember there was a one image with
the orange columns my space is 20 feet
tall the columns are 17 feet tall so
they were hanging you know a foot off
the ground and a foot and a half and a
foot and a half or something and so any
time we were looking at the bottom of
the column
when we were testing the touch sensor we
could see our hands on the sensor and
the bottom of the column so there was a
line of sight
so it was really clear that when i was
touching this you know orange orange
orange orange orange orange you could
make that connection and the people that
we had in could could make that
connection in the space we hung the
columns like up there so you're doing
this and the reaction is up there you
can't you can no longer see the railing
sensor
and and so people weren't figuring it
out at all because you you'd be touching
this or tabbing or something and it's
changing colors and so whichever color
it is is the color that gets added so
you can kind of choose what color but
not if you can't not if you can't look
you know you gotta be like doing like
that um so we changed that so that the
bottom of the columns i don't know if
you remember but now they flash white
and they have this color that matches
the hand railing so there's like a
parallel to the sensor and the railing
in the bottom of each column so you can
you can very clearly see oh wait wait
wait even though you're not licking your
hand so that just blinds i mean that was
just
something i didn't think about that how
hot that that distance would change
things so sometimes even your best
attempts
you know don't you need to adjust
something on site
from what you've said um
through your work you've almost
pre-empted
uh things that have been added into uh
social or techno technological devices
for example we talked about the
accelerometer which you worked with
before it was in the iphone or a motion
sensor
uh before they connect um now you're
talking about uh curved
screens right when you see that coming
in with the samsung phone so it seems
that this like experimentative
artwork or this interactive art that
you're doing
is
very much tied to uh social or
technology right so i wanted to hear you
comment on where do you think uh
that overlap is and how experimentative
art would
wear technology
that's great yeah so there's there
there's big areas that i'm not really
working in i think that's sort of data
space too right like people
again we alluded to it before people are
asking like what if you take some data
feed of like twitter or like other kind
of information people call me a lot and
say can you make an installation with
like
data about our company or whatever so
that's i think those are really
interesting areas it's just i am like
interested in you in you know this
physical immediate physical presence so
um so just as an aside those those are
sort of areas i'm not looking at um wait
what what's the question how am i
interacting with people with technology
it seems like
this is really like
and it's it's becoming more like
intrinsic in our lives especially with
this boom and wearables so where do you
think that your work would influence
positivity
i mean i think i that um eric palos is
at berkeley has this amazing slide
lecture where he shows a lot of things
like google maps michael neymar did a
thing called aspen movie map you know 10
or 15 years before that which was
effectively google maps
even twitter was basically the the
people that started that you know
acknowledge it was based on an artist
project around the world economic forum
where they wanted people to be able to
quickly communicate about where they
were gathering you know to protest and
stuff so i think if we really know our
history that artists are often you know
opening up these weird spaces that are
not you know because we have a lot more
freedom than like a corporation to take
risk
to sort of question things it just it's
a bit structural it's like well that's
what we do you know and that's what we
try to learn how to do so i think that's
i don't know if that's particular
uh to me
i mean obviously i'm engaging with
technology so there's some artists that
still are working in traditional media
but i think if you're
if you're thinking about what you would
like to see differently in our society
and trying to make examples that that
show some possibility there that
ultimately those hopefully i mean i do
hope that those get incorporated into
like what happens because
you know i don't didn't want a world
where we only just sat in front of our
computers all the time
and i still don't want a world where
we're just like
face planted into our screens all the
time so i think um
again in this in this proposal for the
transparent screens when i was talking
with michelle if i'm going to
collaborate with again i think the idea
of like distributed screens you know
where each pixel or part of the screen
isn't in a an xy grid
um and that they could each like be
wi-fi communicate you know right now you
take the screen buffer and you send it
out most mostly in commercial devices
anyway to an xy grid and even if that
grid is going to curve
there's a certain structure to that
information what if every pixel was
anywhere and it had like an ip address
or something i mean that might not be
the best way to organize it right but
like then the screen could come apart
and come back together it's not a flat
thing that even has to have a rectangle
anymore like you it and maybe if they
know the relationship between each other
how information is mapped to that can
change so i think we're i think we're
really still like daguerreotypes to
photography
in terms of
of how we have digital information
overlaid on our physical world and that
could mean like in fabrics or or other
things or in our bodies that gets kind
of creepy but you know there are artists
there's a lot of artists like
experimenting with like embedded you
know cyber cyborgy type things google
glass is getting a little close to that
right so what does that mean for us as
humans
um
things good things to think about
seems like
you you talk you think of a lot about
fluidity of time and
um
as an artist you decide you want
especially given that technology is
moving faster yeah i mean i do talk so
there's a conflict in that which maybe
you know this move towards working with
glass i'm thinking about you know i
don't but i don't i'm not so interested
that my art is going to be here in 30
years it's just while it's around i want
it to be interesting right so i do
really look at a lot of this stuff as
sort of extended performance art
you know it's it's a transient form
ultimately the technology
so i'm pretty comfortable with that you
know i you know that the alternative is
to work in bronze or oil paint but i
just i don't think that brings up these
questions that the other person just
asked of like what is our relationship
to all this stuff so i want to be doing
that and therefore i'm making
fairly transient things but i'd like
them to be interesting while while they
can still function
and not not be disposable in that sense
the environmental issue of you know all
this crap that we're putting out is
something i'm starting to think more
about but i'm not quite sure i want to
play with this stuff so i i don't know
how
we look at the you know piles of
crt screens and lcd screen you know like
just the huge amounts of garbage we're
creating like i'm i'm that that's an
another question worth thinking about
you asked
around yeah after i have an hour after
now to talk afternoon
thank you guys and i'm here so don't be
a stranger if you have ideas or want to
collaborate or something
you